[Music]  today we're at chocolate day they test  us and we're gonna learn how it's made  [Music]  so this is where the four day process  starts after the beans are taken from  the fruit and the process done all by  hand this here is the tool that's used  to ground the cocoa beans into a thick  paste we have just ground out all the  chocolate beans into that case and added  the sugar the chocolate here is cut into  four ounce chunks and then each of those  is turn into one of these round tablets  and each one of these fourths can be  used to make hot chocolate drink and  it's done on the special mat called a  faff day so we just put in two tablets  of chocolate to make four cups and the  water has to be 90 degrees in order for  all the chocolate to melt  we just finished brewing our hot  chocolate and now we're gonna drink it  out of the box dawn it's a traditional  watermelon cuff so  [Music]